what's up everyone Welcome to Austin for
our very first fantastic Fest interview
this is also my first fantastic Fest so
you are my first fantastic Fest
interview ever oh my goodness this is
exciting we're all first time Garza Dan
Brown congratulations on your lucky day
thank you thank you very very very good
film a good film that clearly I like our
audience might not know about it yet so
Dan I'm going to give this duty to you
can you give everyone a brief synopsis
of your movie yeah I'm really bad at
this so if it sounds bad I think it's
still a pretty good movie the the basic
concept is um a man wealthier man wins
the lottery and does it right in front
of somebody else who would like that
money for himself and he robs him and
then you sort of have like a you know
basically a hostage situation with
everybody who was in the store at the
same time there's a cop who comes around
the corner things just kind of spiral
out of control and we just sort of watch
what people are willing to do for 150 $6
million you got it you got it and I feel
like you should be good at giving a
description of the scenario because this
is something that went from short to
feature film and I had read in our uh
press notes I believe that you said that
there was a lot of interest in turning
it into a feature after the short came
out what did that interest look like and
why did you turn it down
then interest was like uh it came out a
while ago and like it's when the
contained Thriller was super hot and so
I was getting a lot of like I got a lot
of meetings asking for feature and the
short has a very like I was sort of I'm
still very into like tragedy I guess but
this short it was very much a tragic
ending and I didn't feel like making I I
was like well what would I do with this
I would have to change this I think I
don't think it would be satisfying in
the same way as a movie um so I didn't
want to just make a feature I think as
part of it so I kind of and then I had a
completely like unsellable script I was
like let's make this thing it was like
anti-war anti everything it was really a
a mess but um so it was kind of like I
just took a bunch of meetings and I just
didn't feel like that was the right time
and maybe I think also some of just my
own personal I was kind of more hopeful
about certain things I guess at the time
that things were going to get maybe a
little bit better and that some of the
things that I felt like were really
maybe were going to be a little less
relevant and then like it was clearly
still very relevant and I was like oh
this was felt like it was just growing
in the back of my mind watching things
happening and I was like okay I think
there's a lot more I can do here and
that sort of gave me the kind of idea to
be like okay I know how to make this
work for me as a feature and how to kind
of help flesh it out and make a story
that I would be happy with is there a
specific thing in the feature version
that you would call your break story
idea the thing that convinced you that
like yes I do have a feature idea on
this now I think the main one was that a
rich person would win the lottery that
was sort of like okay that works that I
can make sense of as like cuz before I
was just like a sweet old guy and he
want a bunch of money and I felt like
that's a different feeling than like
someone who didn't deserve it didn't
need it didn't want it then I just feel
like oh that's that has something to say
and I could see how that would make it
more interesting and more powerful I
think great success having relevant
topics and a hugely entertaining
Thriller too that's that's the the ideal
combination with something like this
thank you all right Jessica so he's a
first time feature filmmaker there there
was a particular quote I think Dan you
said this in our production notes if we
could find a cast that would be
interested in taking a chance on a
director who had never made a feature
maybe it could happen so for you what
was it about him in the script that made
you think like Yep this is a guy and
material that's worth taking a chance on
um it was a pretty easy
decision not one I had to spend a lot of
time on um I read a lot of you know well
not currently given our the current
state of the industry but when we are up
and running I read many scrip scripts in
a week and there are some easy NOS some
sometimes but Dan script was definitely
not uh a no it was a yes I was really
interested in doing something different
than um past work uh a challenge um
getting down in the trenches and the
dirt with you and everyone else and um
really going for it I also had seen a
short film of his called color TV No
Vacancy and I really loved it I I really
it was so specific and it had its own
style and voice and point of view and
perspective and I knew Dan had stuff to
say and that's the most important thing
I think when looking at these um scripts
or you know these newbies or first-time
directors I told Dan I was like don't
you worry I've seen you know there are
people who are making their 10th feature
and maybe they should stop so a first
time one is not a first time one is not
you know too scary when everything's on
the paper and everything's in his brain
and there's past work that backs him up
I love seeing a first-time future
filmmaker tackle material like this
which with uh such Clarity and Authority
I feel like that's the that's the ideal
starting point is knowing exactly what
you're making and how to execute it and
I get the feeling that you did that here
I want to ask you about casting Jessica
now because another thing that I was
reading was that her self tape just blew
you away so what was it about her self
tape that set her audition apart from
the other tapes you
received um I don't want to SP B about
anything else I just like it was just
like a great tape it was we had been I
was just looking you know what I mean
and I had gotten great tapes in but it
wasn't quite right yet and you had this
one it was just very it had strength it
had vulnerability it had all the
elements that I was really hoping for
and then I just remember being very
excited
and there's a story I shouldn't tell
well now I want to
hear said that to me it's about me I
really want to know no cuz we have cuz
you know I think when you're you're
making a movie and you have no back up
really and there wasn't a lot of money
and so I just sort of felt like you're
kind of like an exposed person I think
which makes sense um and like anyone
could say no at any time and I remember
we had to do audition with somebody else
for a part and I was like I was like oh
no I didn't and he didn't work and that
oh terribly human being
but I you know I feelit less bad cuz my
manager was like how did that read go
and I was like um and it was and I was
like oh no do she think like that's her
part sting partner is she going to be
like is this like and no
and it was just more so I was very
nervous at that moment she's going to
say no she's going to think this is her
co-star and this this is terrible he's
very good is it was it was just they
have the right chemistry let's say that
yeah it's always interesting to get
insight you know a look behind the
curtain at that process because there
there is a significant amount of mixing
and matching that goes on in order to
find the perfect balance which is what
you do with your core ensemble in the
film ultimately thank you I mean it we
got really good offers too from like
bigger name and stuff that were
interested in it but it was like offer
only and I wasn't going to do that
unless and so it just sort of there was
really good interest in the script but
it was just sort of I wanted to see what
you were going to do and I remember even
talking about cuz I feel like you have
this wonderful story to tell I don't
want to give anything away about the
movie but like but you go on like a
journey that I was like okay I'm really
excited about this part of it um we get
to see an unexpected kind of hero come
forward I was really excited about that
was like one of the ideas again when it
became like an idea have a feature
that was that was the thing that cracked
it but the thing that before was always
like oh I think there's something really
fun I watched my wife uh just have a
natural birth and like I was like oh
this is an amazing powerful thing I want
the hero like I want you she can do
anything there was like a part of her
that switched over Midway and I was like
oh this is amazing I haven't seen
someone turn this into something it's
normally like a certain way to handle
babies and like really like in another
movie I think they' be like oh and then
she has the baby when it's really
stressful and you're like but that's not
actually how your human body works that
actually like your body won't let you
have a baby when it's like in a
stressful time like in um it's a good
movie but what's the one where she has
birth and bathtub and oh um this I feel
like I'm talking
blunt Kinski Place yeah but like you
don't I was thinking of a different one
but it happens right and it's like
that's like a anyways I just felt like
it'd be fun to have that kind of like
powerful female character pregnant she's
going to take care of things and like
kind of watch that person kind of rise
from the background to the foreground so
I was really excited about that to build
on that ol little Jessica when you're
jumping into filming this what quality
of hers were you most excited to get to
play but then also what is something
about her that wound up being more
creatively fulfilling to tap into than
you ever could have imagined um well
definitely to add on to what Dan said
the complexity of her and the way that
she surprised me on the page is uh
probably what interested me the most
about her and um what I think will
interest other people all human beings
are very complex and and especially when
you're put into situations that are life
or death um and I really resonated with
her
um uh with her being okay to be
vulnerable all the
time cuz I tend to be on the vulnerable
side you know I uh um but then I I I I
loved her also ability to put that in
her pocket and survive and fight for
what she believes in for you know what
she wants what she needs in this life um
all of those things I maybe lost track
of the question but I no those are all
good qualities to highlight and I think
well well highlight the the multitude of
layers I would hope to be as strong as
she is I don't want to give myself the
credit there but I think that's what um
really draws me into her and I think
what will draw in other people I did
want to highlight angus's wonderful work
in the film but actually more so
something that I read in the notes about
how he carried himself on set which I
think is something very special Dan you
said this he would openly celebrate
everyone around him so can you maybe
each give me an example of a Time on set
when he celebrated you when you needed
it when you needed that source of
confidence well I don't know I don't
want to take your story I unless it's
the same it could not be I just remember
there's like a scene and he's not in the
scene I can't talk about the scene but
he's not in the scene
really but he and he's just sort of like
kind of almost background he doesn't
need to be there in some ways and he was
just like there and he would like we do
a take and he would like cheer everybody
on and say that everyone was doing a
great job like I just don't I've never
seen that before from anybody else where
he was like great job everybody yeah was
out there on set when he didn't need to
be it's easy to go back to your trailer
to go to get a snack or whatever the
case may be and he was uh always present
and um always not just willing but
excited to be there at 4:00 in the
morning you know into hour 10 or
whatever it was and um excited to work
and to get to know people from you know
from me a co-star to Dan as director to
Caterers you know everyone on set um he
knew their names and wanted to get to
know who they were no better partner to
have on a project like this making any
film for that matter I'm a big believer
that uh film cast and Cruz need to feel
like a family because we pour everything
we have into making these movies and
it's not easy so I want to talk about
more of the Ensemble right now Jessica
I'll give you this can you give me an
example of a scene partner you had in
this movie where your approach to the
work was very similar where the second
you met you were immediately in sync but
then I also want the opposite someone
with a different approach that
challenged you to adapt and maybe try
something new and for the better okay um
I am very lucky that me and my my baby
daddy Elliot got great we we got along
great I can't tell you how many
like silly photos and videos I have of
me and my and him and my phone and we're
joking around and laughing and it was
great cuz we could do that in one second
and then and then the next second when
the camera started rolling we were ready
to go for the next thing and so we had
great chemistry luckily and I hadn't met
him before we like I know it was really
risky it could have been scary could
have been scary cuz we did not have a
like a chem read or anything but uh I
lefted out cuz he's a great guy and um
we just had similar uh
you know the same flow we operated in
the same flow um maybe someone who
challenged me was actually Angus he has
um he's so charismatic and so magnetic
um but can be he was unpredictable
sometimes or like would do something
that I didn't expect or that I you know
couldn't have guessed or wasn't ready
for and having to listen and be there
and be present with him moment to moment
and um kind of let him take me for a
ride
was uh so much fun and different than um
maybe my Approach was a which is could
be a little bit more rigid or you know
um it's all different but it all worked
out and it's all great that's making me
think of a question that I love asking
CU When you make a movie you want to
plan plan plan and go into the
production ready to get everything done
but sometimes when when things go wrong
that unexpected magic you can find is
better than anything you had originally
planned for so can you maybe give me an
example of a day on set when things
weren't going to plan you found a good
way to Pivot and a scene in the movie is
better off for it I think actually I
I've told the story before so but I feel
bad but I think one of them was I had
written a scene um sort of Angus has
this moment where he sort of in the
script it was very like a generic
version of what kind of like a kind of
empty vessel of a human being would talk
about not that sounds terrible but you
know what I mean like I don't he wasn't
like think deep thinking in the in the
script he was more like a motor mouth
kind of like brash and jumped into
something um which so he just sort of
like listed off things that he would do
if he was a million which is very
generic um and that was sort of the
point and Angus was running the line and
it just wasn't working right and he's
like I'm not really and this was great
but Angus was like and I think because
we just had a good working relationship
it was easy to sort of shift it if it
needed to shift or he or would be
sometimes be like oh we can lose that
line like no I really want to keep that
line but this was one of those cases
where like it wasn't working and what he
was saying wasn't connecting so it was
sort of I remember him running the line
I remember even you saying like he said
oh live life like Pablo and you're like
oh that's great so I was like okay I'll
Trust the room that that's working right
and he just sort of like kind of did
almost like a monologue that was all
kind of his own some of it had been on
the page but most of it was just stuff
he was making off and really was like he
took what it was written kind of like in
a weird like just shifted it around a
little bit and then he added a bunch of
stuff at the end that made it like
poignant m in a way that I hadn't kind
of expected and so that was really just
kind of like a lovely moment where he
like took the scene in a place and like
portrayed like a sadness and a deepness
that the character didn't have in that
moment I felt like it was much stronger
for that I am always eager to highlight
unsung heroes on a film and ads are
often the unsung heroes on a set who
keep it up and running and you said
about Mitchie that Mitchie has an energy
and a spark that you needed to push on
through all this so how did Mitchie do
that and what qualities does she have
that you hope to see in more ads in the
future um well she was just I she had a
wonderful energy and just a great kind
of caring atmosphere about her which is
sort of definitely what I wanted as well
um uh yeah she there's a St I don't need
to I there was another ad on for like a
second I was like this isn't working we
need to find someone else and he was
only there for a day and then thankfully
we found Mitchy um and she was just sort
of just this wonderful person uh we were
working on it she was excited about the
script I remember going over to her
house and like all right let's look on
the schedule a little bit cuz she came
in a little late so it was just sort of
like let's work on it together and then
she just had like she just sort of
really cared about what we were doing
and what the process was going to be
like and she would you know there I
remember we had done some like part of
just like doing a small movie is like
some stuff wasn't all the way done we
were working on the store still kind of
while we were already shooting it I
heard about the production designer too
and you stepped in and did a significant
amount of work in that department as
well but Mitchy was like she was like I
was kind of you know you're just sort of
she's like she started hanging tinsel
around she like you're making a
Christmas movie so she kept like that
kind of thing and then she would just be
a fun person to have around on set and
just sort of a real sweetheart that kind
of again I think the exact kind of
energy that I think the set needed it
was an intense shoot it was a fast shoot
and to have someone who really so openly
again I think caring and she just really
loved Angus too when everyone got along
with her she was efficient but good at
taking care of people which you know is
harder than you think to find both
qualities in someone and she had she had
both I think sometimes that rle can kind
of take on like an
adversarial but they don't have to and I
thought like she did a really great job
it like getting people together and
keeping us on track and keeping things
like getting creative and you know
keeping stay you know having ideas and
all the great things so I always take
the opportunity to highlight in ad
because it is very very challenging to
find that balance between being
efficient and getting work done but also
doing it with kindness and enthusiasm so
when I hear someone who can do that I
like to highlight them before I let you
go some silly questions about winning
the lottery I'm sure you're going to get
a lot of these while you're here I I
hope these are somewhat original okay so
the first thing I'm putting you on the
spot you have to just like do what I say
immediately after I say the thing okay
you win the lottery in a public place MH
show me your
reaction like on your face right now
that's it I don't based off this I would
be very good I guess that's fair that's
fair I feel I feel like I wouldn't be
able to contain myself and I would give
myself away in a heartbeat I feel um I
guess I'm more of like that oh kind of
person where like I take it in really
quick and shut down I shut down I feel
like if it happened the way it happens
in the movie where it's so clear and
accurate I I would have like a holy
kind of reaction but if it was on me to
figure out if I won I would just stand
there with a Blank Stare on my face like
assuming I was wrong the whole time my
first reaction honestly would be to
check my phone and then to check it
again and then to check it on someone
else's phone be like is this real and I
would want to check it a few times okay
so now you both win the lottery who is
the first person in your life that you
tell definitely my
mom definitely my mom and then my dad
but yeah those two mine's easy it's my
wife just called okay smart answers both
right answers all right you win the
lottery you can buy an unlimited supply
of your favorite thing in the world what
are you buying Hot
Cheetos I respect that answer so much
great answer that was the first thing
that came to my brain and I couldn't
think of anything else to lie about
that's the truth I don't know if this I
don't know this is exactly what your
question was but I would probably buy
like international travel tickets no
that counts okay cuz I think I'd love to
go around the world that that would be
like the first more I was better than my
my mind went down that route like like I
would just buy and this is the dumbest
answer I could give I would buy a
lifetime supply of uh Whole Foods peanut
butter but it's F like the point why I
like it is it's fresh ground so it would
go bad so I don't know that would work
there's just so much daily guilt we all
have um getting our snacks you know it's
like I know I don't need the snack but I
want this snack and so if I could get
rid of my day-to-day guilt about snacks
it's also the mentality that I need to
know that I have an absurd amount of my
snacks so will never run out so that
that is like my dream question that I
would want to be able to answer if I won
the lottery all right last one here you
can Finance the dream project of your
choice what is that project when I would
be in or one that I just would love to
see you have all the power in the world
SP all this
money um the first thing that comes to
my head cuz that's all I'm going off
Instinct here is uh Kill Bill 3 I would
just love to see that I know that's kind
of like a fan you know um fanfic kind of
dream and hope and wish that I know you
know we're not you know is not happening
but I just would love to see what that
would look like with um the daughter
coming back and seeing um Thurman on the
screen again all those things yeah
that's a great answer I'm sure there's
plenty of money to do that if there
interested in it so I don't know but I
he's interested yeah exactly so now I'm
thinking about a million projects that I
want to bring back I can name drop quite
a few I would Finance another season of
Ash versus evil dead feel like that's a
good fantastic festy answer oh that's
that reminds me I would do The Newsroom
the HBO oh that's a good choice too yeah
I missed that show especially in this
time you know what I mean of crazy world
that came out in 2012 or something like
that it's so much a strange
that's for sure what you got for us Dan
um dream project let me think was that
too loud that you need an answer to this
question now you come you come to a
festival with a really hot feature debut
you got to be ready to go I have a movie
that I want to do next which is uh it's
called the afterlife it's about two
brothers who escape a suicide Cults and
then there's like a genre Twist on it I
think it's really exciting um but if I
had all the money in the world maybe it
would this is maybe a nerdy answer but I
would like to do the slaughterhouse 5
that book is just amazing and I love
Kurt Von and I love the I just feels
like the way your memory works right
where like you're living your moment
right now and your head somewhere else I
just felt like it's a wonderful book
that I'm obsessed with all good answers
all good answers if I win the lottery
I'll come back and I'll Finance your
next future wonderful your your next
feature will get financing it will
happen because what we do in the
collider interview studio is we manifest
things so your next movie is going to
get finance and also everyone out there
is going to see your lucky day because
again I mean it sincerely the movie is
excellent huge congratulations thank you
thank you so
much